Narrator: JESSI, GRANT, AND TORY
HAVE ALL BUT BUSTED THE MYTH
THAT SMUGGLERS COULD DRIVE
ON A MOONLESS NIGHT
WITHOUT HEADLIGHTS.
ALL RIGHT,
SO IT LOOKS LIKE THE NAKED EYE
JUST ISN'T UP TO THE DEMANDS
OF THIS SMUGGLING MISSION,
WHICH MEANS IT'S TIME
TO DEPLOY SOME TECHNOLOGY.
CHECK THIS OUT --
NIGHT-VISION GOGGLES.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THESE BABIES ARE
STATE-OF-THE-ART,
THIRD GENERATION
FROM B.E. MEYERS.
THEY TAKE AVAILABLE LIGHT
AND AMPLIFY IT
INTO AN IMAGE WE CAN SEE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF TECHNOLOGY
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
YEAH, SO I'M GONNA DO A RUN IN
THE DARK USING NOTHING BUT THESE
AND SEE HOW I DO.
OKAY, BUT THIS TIME, NO
LOLLYGAGGING AROUND THE TRACK
AT A SNAIL'S PACE.
LET'S MAKE IT REALISTIC.
I'LL BE CHASING AFTER YOU
LIKE I'M THE COP.
Narrator:
THESE NIGHT-VISION GOGGLES
ARE LEGAL IN THE U.S.
BUT NOT IN CANADA.
STILL, I DON'T SUPPOSE
THAT WOULD DETER
A DEPRAVED SYRUP SMUGGLER.
YOU READY?
I'M READY.
ALL RIGHT. HERE WE GO.
OKAY, LIGHTS OUT!
Narrator: SO, CAN TECHNOLOGY
WORK WHERE THE HUMAN EYE FAILED?
TORY'S FIRST FEW LAPS
ARE FAST AND BOUNCY.
[ TIRES SCREECH ]
Tory:
SEEING IS NOT A PROBLEM.
BEING ABLE TO JUDGE
HOW FAR YOU ARE FROM OBJECTS
OR SEEING AROUND YOU --
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
I MEAN,
IT IS TRULY TUNNEL VISION.
YOU HAVE NO DEPTH OF FIELD.
YOU HAVE NO PERIPHERAL VISION.
I MEAN, I MUST HAVE BANGED INTO
THE WALLS HALF A DOZEN TIMES.
Narrator: NOW OFFICER JESSI
GIVES CHASE.
AND YOU GET THE FEELING
IT WON'T BE LONG
BEFORE JUSTICE CATCHES UP
WITH OUR SCOUNDREL.
Tory: AND THEN YOU HAVE THE COP
CHASING YOU,
AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S A WHOLE NEW GAME
WHERE IT'S LIKE NOW YOU HAVE THE
STRESS OF SOMEBODY CATCHING YOU,
AND YOU'RE HAVING
TO REACT QUICKLY.
[ JESSI LAUGHS ]
Narrator: BUT WHAT'S
THE ULTIMATE VERDICT?
I MEAN, YOU CAN DRIVE
WITH THE NIGHT-VISION GOGGLES,
BUT AS SOON
AS YOU STARTED CHASING ME,
I HAD TO SPEED UP, AND MY
REACTION TIME HAD TO SPEED UP.
AND HAVING TUNNEL VISION,
BASICALLY,
I TOTALLY MISJUDGED
THAT LAST TURN
AND CRASHED INTO THE WALL,
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU SMACKED
INTO ME AND STOPPED ME.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: SO, DRIVING
WITH NIGHT-VISION GOGGLES
MIGHT HELP A LITTLE,
BUT LESS THAN WE'D HOPED.
THE MYTH IS FIRST TESTED,
TOTALLY BUSTED.
AND IS IT DANGEROUS?
YEAH. ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.